[موسيقى]
اسمي مراد انا جندي سابق
انضممت الى شركه بافلن العسكريه الخاصه
سنه 2015
[موسيقى]
بتاع مصرابه قيل لنا صراحه منذ البدايه
ان عملنا يشمل خوض معارك وانشطه عسكريه
تنجم عنها اصابات وصدمات نفسيه
واحتماليه التعرض للموت كبير
طلبوا منا ان نحسم امرا
فلا فرصه للتراجع بعد النزول الى الميادين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في السادسه والخمسين من العمر امضى حياته
في استخدام الاسلحه الناريه عندما كان من
مغاوير الجيش السوفيتي ثم قاتلا ماجورا في
عالم الجريمه في سيبيريا
[موسيقى]
هذه هي الجوائز النموذجيه لمجموعه فاجنر
الصلبان السوداء والشهيره
وهذه ميداليه بعد الانتصار على تنظيم
الدوله
اخبرني صديق عزيز عن شركه قال انها ستثير
اهتمام حتما
بحكم تدريب العسكري وحاجتها الى اشخاص
مثلي
يريد
الى مكتب التجنيد
ولم يكن احد منا يتساءل حقا عن الوضع
القانوني الدقيق لهذا الكيا
فما الفائده من طرح الاسئله
المال اهم دوافعي فنحن نتقادر راتب مجزيه
بالمعايير الروسيه
960 يورو شهريا خلال فتره التدريب ثم
يرتفع الراتب ليصل الى 1800 يورو نظير
المهمات الاولى في الخارج
لم يسبق لاحد من قوات فاجنر ان ادلى
بشهادته علانيه
مجموعه بدات قصتها في دومباس على الحدود
الروسيه شرق اوكرانيا
ارض يعتبرها فلاديمير بوتين جزءا من الحرم
الروسي
وتتنازعها تدعمهم
في شتاء عام 2015 وصل نحو 300 مقاتل لدعم
الانفصال
هؤلاء من جند مجموعه بادنر منظمه تستمد
اسمها من لقب مؤسسها
وهو من قدام المحاربين في القوات الخاصه
الروسيه
كان الاسم الحربيه لديميتري اوتن في فتره
خدمته في الجيش الروسي لماذا هذا اللقب
لان اوت كين من اشد المعجبين بهتلر
والرموز النازيه على جسده وشوم مستوحاه من
الريخ الثالث والرسوم الفاشيه ويقال انه
ما يزال على التزام تام بهذه الايديولوجيه
والى اليوم لا يزال قائدا
[موسيقى]
عشره الاف رجل خدموا على الارجح تحت امرته
منذ سنه 2014
تمكن فريق عمل البرنامج من الاطلاع على
قائمه اعدتها اجهزه الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه
وتضم هويات اربعه الاف واربعمائه واربعه
وثمانين من المقاتلين باسمائهم وتواريخ
ميلادهم وما ينسب اليهم من بطولات وحتى
تذكراتهم الشخصيه
لتحويل مجموعه صغيره الى جيش بهذا الحجم
تطلب الامر تمويلا من ثري لسلطه ونفوذ
اسمه
بعد قضائه ثمانيه سنوات في السجن امتلك
مطعما قبل ان يراكم ثروه طائله مع بدايه
الالفيه الثانيه حيث صار مكلفا بتموين
المطاعم المدرسيه في موسكو وسكنات وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وبفضل هذا النشاط وقربه من
السلطات اكتسب لقب طباخ
ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي للتدخل في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه عام 2016
حيث يزعم انه مول حمله تضليل على الانترنت
لصالح دونالد ترامبو
انتشر مقاتلوا فاجنر في جميع انحاء العالم
على مدى السنوات الثمان الماضيه
في اوكرانيا ومدغشقر وموزمبيق والسودان
وفي جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وسوريا وليبيا
غير ان الرئيس افلاديمير بوتين لا يزال
مصرا على رفض الاعتراف بوجود
هل لك ان تؤكد لنا ان الفين من مقاتلي
فاجنر منتشرون في ليبيا وان مرتزقه الروسا
يقاتلون في هذا البلد
الرجال ذهبوا لقتال من اجل بلدهم يعني
فذلك يمكنها من انكار المسؤوليه عن ايه
انتهاكات قد ترتكبها هذه الميليشيا وكان
روسيا تقول لا شان لنا بهذا هي منشاه خاصه
مستقله لاصله لموسكو بها ومن واجه مشكلات
مع فاجنر فليخاطب مسؤوليها
[موسيقى]
الالتقاء بممثل قانوني عن فاجنر ضرب من
المحال فهي شركه سريه لا وجود لها قانونيا
تطلب الامر من فريق عمل الفيلم اكثر من
عام من التحقيق للعثور على رجل على صله
بالمنظمه وافق على الادلاء بشهادته
وفي روسيا شرقي الاورال واسمه فاسيلي
[موسيقى]
يتنقل باسيل بانتظام الى دومباس للقتال
الى جانب الانفصاليين
وفي روسيا يدرب ويجدد مقاتلين اخرين
في عام 2020 انخرط عشره منهم في عمليات
[موسيقى]
من هذا النوع المطلوب متعاونون براتب قدره
1800 يورو الشروط اللعقه البدنيه واللياقه
الطبيه وجواز سفر للابتعاد الى الخارج
يرسل الرجل الوثائق المطلوبه واي يشكن في
امر مترشح ما كان يكون صحفيا متخفيا او ما
شابه ذلك يخضعه لاختبار كشف الكذب واذا
اتضح ان كل شيء على ما يرام يتم توظيفه
وان كان قناصه متمرسا فمن الطبيعي ان يتم
تحويله الى مناطق القتال
[موسيقى]
بحكم خبرته العسكريه ارسل مارات الى سوريا
عام 2015
سوريا من مناطق الانتشار الرئيسيه لمجموعه
باجنر
حدثونا عن رجل عظيم اسمه بشار الاسد قالوا
انه رجل طيب يحاول وحيدا مع جيشه البطل
محاربه الامبرياليه العالميه هذا الرجل
الطيب بحاجه للمساعده
هناك في سوريا عالم المجتمع الدولي بوجود
مجموعه بادنر في البدايه قاتلت قوات الى
جانب الجيش السوري ضد تنظيم الدوله كما في
تدمر مثلا عام 2017
دائمات وزمرته بمهمات اخرى مثل استعاده
حقول النفط والغاز وتامينها في الثامن من
شباط فبراير عام 2018 وفي ظلمه الليل شن
المقاتلون هجوما على محطه الطابيه وهي
محطه طاقه في دير الزور
هناك اصطدموا بالقوه التي كانت تسيطر
عليها من الاكراد الذين تدعمهم امريكا
[موسيقى]
اعتقدوا ان 200 من مقاتلينر لقوا حتفهم
تحت القنابل ليلتها
[موسيقى]
شهاده الوفاه هذه وصلتني معناشه
كان سيرجي ابن ريما من قتلى دير الزور
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قيل اليه ان مغامرته ستحسن من مستوى
معيشته كل شيء مرتبط بالمال فالشاب يريد
ان يحظى برغد العيش ولكن احلامه كانت
مجنونه حصل على قرض وعندما حل موعد تسديده
لم يجد مالا لتغطيه دينه
هذا هو لن تخطئه عيني ولو وسط الف
كان سيرجي في الثالثه
وتيتم طفله ولم تتلقى اسرته اي تعويض
[موسيقى]
تمنيت لو عمل معامله البطل
وان يعترف به جنديا نظاميا يذو عن السلام
لا مرتزقا
ابني لم يكن قاتلا ماجورا
كانت مسرح المواجهه المباشره الوحيده التي
تعترف فيها القوه الغربيه بمواجهه بادنر
ومع انها لم تؤدي الى صراع مفتوح الى ان
المعركه ازاحت الغطاء عن شبح حرب بين
الكتلتين
[موسيقى]
ودائره المقربه منه في فكره استعاده عظمه
روسيا في العالم يريدون ان تحظى روسيا
بالتقدير مجددا وان ينظر اليها كقوه
عالميه
مقتنعون بضروره اضعاف الغرب وشق وحدته
وزرع بذور الشقاق فيه فكلما ضعف الغرب
تستفيد روسيا ويقوى موقفها على الساحه
الدوليه
[موسيقى]
هل هذا يعني احياء الحرب البارده
تلك الحرب لم تتوقف يوما لم تصل بعد الى
مرتبه الامبراطوريه ولكنها تسعى الى هذه
الصفه مجددا وهل لفاقنر دور في هذا نعم
فاغنر واحده من الادوات لتحقيق الهدف
اداه تتمتع بموارد مهمه وتحظى بالدعم في
اعلى هرم الدوله الروسيه
[تصفيق]
هذا ما خلص اليه رسلان الذي يقود فريقا
بحثيا اسمه استجلاء كوامن النزاعات وهي
منظمه استقصائيه تنشط على الانترنت وتمكن
افرادها من اعداد قائمه بالمعدات التي
تستخدمها باجنر
[موسيقى]
من المحطات المهمه في عملنا وصولنا لموقع
قاعده فاجنر في ملكينو جنوبيه روسيا حيث
تربط منشاه عسكريه رسميه للقوات الخاصه
الروسيه هكذا يتضح ان المليشيا ليست
مجموعه افراد مستقلين يمولهم ثري نافذ ايا
كان بل كيان سري تابع للسلطات الروسيه
ولوزاره الدفاع
وهل يستطيع هذا الجيش التحرك دون اذن
حكومي
لا يمكنهم ذلك فالحكومه هي التي تتكفل
بتجهيزهم والرجال في كثير من الاحيان جنود
احتياط يؤمن لهم الماكل والملبس ويستخدمون
وسائل نقل وامداد تابعه لوزاره الدفاع
تنشرهم في الاماكن التي يتعين عليهم خوض
عمليات قتاليه فيها من الواضح ان فاجنر
تابعه للحكومه وانها هيكل من هياكل الدوله
الروسيه
انا صحفي في جريده نوفايا جازيتا المعارضه
قضيت معظم صيني حياتي في شرطه
محققا في القضايا الجنائيه وكنت احب عملي
يعود الفضل لهذا الشرطي السابق في كشف
الصله بين مجموعه باجنار والكرملين
[موسيقى]
شاهدت كل مقاطع الفيديو التي صورتها دائره
المراسم الرئاسيه لم اكن املك الى فكره
ضبابيه عن ملامح اوتاكين فجاه رايته جالسا
في لقطه جانبيه انه هذا الرجل ذو الوجه
الاعجى في المميز
ادركت وقتها ان عود كين حضر حفل استقبال
رسمي في الكرملين بحضور الرئيسي
[موسيقى]
كرم الرئيس بوتين مؤسسه بادنر لبطولاته
الحربيه ومنذ ذلك الحين لم يظهر اتقن مره
اخرى في المناسبات العامه
[موسيقى]
صور تقطر دما لتمجيد مصارعي العصر الحديث
وبث الحماس في الجند
[موسيقى]
وافلام على الطريقه
تستخدم فيها شاحنات فاجنر بينما يلعب
المقاتلون ادوارهم الحقيقيه
اغراء لاجتداد مسلحين جددهم
تجند المزيد من الرجال لاغراق مسرح
عملياتها الرئيسي جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
ظلت افريقيا الوسطى في مجال النفوذ
الفرنسي
لكنها اليوم تحت سيطره فاجنر التي نشرت
قواتها هناك منذ عام 2018 لانجاز مهمتين
مراقبه البلد والسيطره على الموارد
الطبيعيه الرئيسيه
بمجرد وصول فريق عمل الفيلم الى بانجي
صادف هؤلاء الرجال المسلحين ذوي الوجوه
الملثمه ودون شارات تظهر هوياتهم وعلى
الرغم من انه في كل مكان فان تصويرهم
ممنوع هذه الصور التقطتها فريق العمل خفيه
من نوافذ سيارته المعتمه
المعلومات التي وصلت الى الفريق تفيد
بانتشار 2000 من المقاتلين الاجانب في
جميع انحاء البلاد
هذا الاحتلال غير المعلن يندد به جونساج
بوكاسا الوزير السابق وابن الامبراطور
الذي حكم جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى في
سبعينيات القرن العشرين وبسبب موقفه هذا
تم منعه من حقه في مغادره افريقيا الوسطى
شركه تغلغلت في جميع مستويات المسؤوليه
الاستراتيجيه في القصر الجمهوري يتكفل شخص
روسي بالجانب الامني نحن نشهد شكلا من
اشكال ارهاب الدوله
تسود الفوضى في افريقيا الوسطى منذ سنه
2013 فالبلاد تشهد حربا اهليه بين الحكومه
المركزيه وجماعات متمرده
بعام 2018 لم تكن الحكومه تسيطر الا على
نحو 20% من مساحه البلاد
ولمحاربه المتمردين استنجدت الدوله بروسيا
التي ارسلت خبراء لتدريب قوات الجيش
النظامي بتفويض من الامم المتحده
تمكن فريق الفيل من الحصول على شريط فيديو
يعود تاريخه الى الثاني من حزيران يونيو
وهي اول مره ترصد فيها انتهاكات فاجنر دون
علمها
صورت اللقطات بطائره مراقبه تابعه لدوله
اخرى وفيها نرى قافله تسير على طريق في
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
وبعد التحقق من الصور بفضل خدمه جوجل ايرث
يمكننا القول ان الموكب كان متوجها الى
مدينه بوكرنجه الواقعه على بعد 500
كيلومتر شمال غرب عاصمه افريقيا الوسطى
قرب حدود تشاد حيث قتل عشره من مقاتلي
فاجنر
[موسيقى]
مركبات الموكب تحمل سمات باجنر وسبق ان
رصدت نماذج مماثله لها في ليبيا بعد
توقفها شرع ثلاثه جنود في استنطاق اثنين
من السكان المحليين على جانب الطريق
[موسيقى]
تمكن احدهما من الفرار نحو الادغال غير ان
مقاتلي فاجنر لاحقوه واطلقوا عليه النار
[موسيقى]
راينا الدخان يخرج من الماسوره وهو اسلوب
التطير الذي مارسه الجيش الروسي خلال
الحرب في الشيشان
[موسيقى]
عند تنفيذ اي هجوم فالمبدا المعمول به هو
الا نترك اي عدو وراءنا حتى الاعداء
المحتملين واذا صدر الامر باحتلال اقليم
لجعله منطقه خضراء فالمطلوب مسح كل شبهه
وشك وبعد تطهير منطقه ماهوله علينا البحث
في كل مكان وفي جميع المنازل وفي حال
العثور على اسلحه مع رجال يجوز القضاء
عليهم ايضا
وفي مثل هذه الاجواء من الخوف اعداد قليله
فقط من الضحايا يوافقون على الادلاء
بشهاداتهم
للامم المتحده حضور في افريقيا الوسطى
لضمان حمايه سكان المدنيين
في تقرير نشر في حزيران يونيو 2021
نددت المنظمه الامميه بالانتهاكات التي
ارتكبها الروس المعروفون باسم افراد الامن
القوات المسلحه من افراد الامن في افريقيا
الوسطى وغيرها مسؤولون عن 240 واقعه
اعتداء
ضحاياها
491 شخصا قتل منهم 144 مدنيا
تعرفت شعبه حقوق الانسان عليهم
وتحققت من هوياتهم
كما يركز التقرير على حاله ماما الملقب
باحد عشر
اختطف ممات ثم اغتيل في شمال افريقيا
الوسطى
[موسيقى]
في بلده كاجابان دورو اعتقل الرجال امن
اخرون تاجرا مسلم الديانه وفي اليوم
التالي عثر على جثته متفحمه على مشارف
المدينه ومقطعه الى اجلاء
[موسيقى]
احمد يعرف الضحيه
وكان شاهدا على الواقعه
رمضان حدث ذلك يوم 27 من شهر رمضان في
حدود الخامسه مساء جاء الروس وسالوه من هو
احد عشر
فاجاب الرجل انا هو فقيده فورا وبداوا في
لكمه قبل ان يحشروه حاشرا في سيارته
كان ممات زن من اغنى التجار في المدينه
بعد نهب منزله اخذه الروس الى الادغال
وعادوا بدونه بعدها باربع ساعات
ذهبنا لمعاينه المكان الذي دفنوا فيه
الجثه لقد سحلوا جثته لاربع مئه متر في
الادغال قبل القائه في حفره للنمل الابيض
على مقربه منه وجدنا دماءا واصفادا
بلاستيكيه وحذاء رجل اخر قتلوه من اجل
المال ثم دفنوه في حفره لاخفاء الجثه حتى
لا يطلب منهم احد اعاده المالدي
الافلات من العقاب هو سيد الموقف والعثور
على ادله الادانه امر صعب للغايه
جيش ظل هذا لا يترك وراءه من القرنين الا
القليل
غير ان هذا الفيديو قد يقلب اللعبه راسا
على عقب
يعود تاريخه لحزيران يونيو 2017 وتم
تصويره في سوريا الضحيه جندي منشق من جيش
النظام
في هذا الفيديو الذي تخالطه موسيقى بهيجه
نرى رجالا مرحيا يتحدثون الروسيه معهم
مطرقه ثقيله يضربون بها رجلا عربيا ملقا
على الارض ثم نرى كيف قطع هؤلاء الرجال
اطرافه وعلقوه من رجليه ثم جزوا راسه
واشعلوا النار في جسده
تعرف دينيس على واحد من مرتكب الجريمه
اسمه ستانلس ديتشكو وهو شرطي سابق من
مواليد العام 1990
لا اعتقد انها حاله فرديه وهذا هو الخطر
الاكبر الذي يمثله وجود هذه القوه المسلحه
المنفلته ليس غريبا ان تحتكر الدوله
استخدام العنف في العالم المتحضر هؤلاء
الناس يعملون خارج اي اطار قانوني اين
القاده المسؤولون من المسؤول اصلا
اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي عن تحديده
للمسؤولين عن ذلك وفي الثالث عشر من كانون
الاول ديسمبر 2021
فرض عقوبات على ثمانيه من اعضاء فاجنر
منهم ديمتري اوتكن على اساس انه امر شخصيا
بتعذيب الجندي السوري المنشق حتى الموت
وان يتم تصوير ذلك ولكن لم يخضع اي شخص
للمتابعه في روسيا حتى الان فهل يرجع ذلك
لنفوذ ما يقوم على تمويل فاغنر
بالاضافه الى مجموعه باجنر يدير يفجن
بريكوجين شركه متعدده الجنسيات تزدهر
انشطتها في مناطق النزاع
[موسيقى]
وفي جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى بسط هذا الرجل
ذو السطوه والنفوذ يده على القطاع الاكبر
ربحيه في البلاد مناجم الالماس والذهب
واكبرها يسمى داسيما
[موسيقى]
وفقا لوثيقه سريه فان القيمه الاجماليه
الخام للمنجم ملياران ونصف المليار يورو
[موسيقى]
يعمل ادم في قطاع المناجم
وقد تمكن من الاطلاع على معلومات سريه
تكشف منظومه سطو على الموارد انشات
هافاجنر
منذ عام 2010
كانت اكس من الكنديه تستغل منجم الذهب
غير ان حكومه افريقيا الوسطى منحت سنه
2019 عقد الامتياز لمؤسسه ميداس للموارد
التي تعرف رسميا على انها
[موسيقى]
تاسست ميداس ما بين الثاني عشر والثالث
عشره من تشرين الثاني نوفمبر 2019 وفي
الخامس عشر من تشرين الثاني نوفمبر تم نشر
دعوه مفتوحه للمناقصات الدوليه على منجم
باسندرو اي بعد تاسيس ميداس بيومين او
ثلاثه فقط هل هذا التواطؤ هو تواطئ سافر
بالنسبه لنا
ديروا المناجم الى ان حكومه افريقيا
الوسطى كانت متواطئه في العمليه فقد كانت
تعرف منذ البدايه ان ميداس ليست ملكاشيه
بل هي شركه روسيه
ميداس للموارد شركه تعدين روسيه تحوز
تصريحا لاستغلال المناجم في منطقه
اثبت التحقيق الذي اجراه فريق الفيلم ان
وراء مؤسسه ميداس ريسز يختفي الشبح يفجين
[موسيقى]
ويبين سجل الشركات الملاغاشيه انها مرتبطه
من خلال مديرها
بكرامت التي تشتري معدات عسكريه نيابه عن
للاستثمار
المسجله في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى والتي
اشارت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه الى
ارتباطها بياسين
كل هذه المعدات اقتنيت من شركه ثالثه
اسمها ام فايننس
وعنوان بريدها الالكتروني مطابق لشركه
الام في امبراطوريه بريكوجين اي كونكورد
للتموين وهي واحده من ثلاث شركات يديرها
رسميا رجل الاعمال الروسي النافذ
[موسيقى]
هو فلكم من الشركات الوهميه ترتبط بشكل
غير مباشر لرجل الاعمال الروسي كل الخيوط
تقود اليه انه نظام هرمي او هو بالاحرى
نظام مركزي ويبدو جليا انه ليس من قبيل
المصادفه وجود لفيف من منشات وهميه يتستر
بعضها على بعض انه نموذج كلاسيكي الطابع
في روسيا ما بعد الاتحاد السوفيتي للاثراء
والاستثمار
في الوثائق الرسميه لجمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى نجد مذكره بشان تطوير منجم الذهب
في الفصل الثامن بعنوان النفقات التشغيليه
في مجال الامن من جانب الاتحاد الروسي
يمكننا قراءه ما يلي
يحق لدوله افريقيا الوسطى ان تحاط علما
بحاله الاستثمار الروسي في مجال الامن
القومي حتى تكون قادره على تدبير نفقات
التعويضات
واضح اذا ان تراخيص التعدين وسيله لدفع
اجور قوات فاغنر التي ارسلت الى جمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى
[موسيقى]
الدوله في موقف العاجز الضعيف لانها لا
تملك ما تدفع به اجوره هؤلاء ولذا فان
افضل حل هو منحهم تصاريح مزيه مثل دسيمه
وهكذا تصبح هذه القوات شبه العسكريه ومجمع
ميداس هم المستفيدين في حين لا تكسب
الدوله شيئا والاسوا من ذلك ان سكان
افريقيا الوسطى لا ينالهم اي شيء من هذه
الثروات
هذه الشركات لجعل نظام نفوذين مربحا في
افريقيا وبما ان لب الموضوع هو كسب المال
اولا وقبل كل شيء فمن الضروري ارساء نموذج
ناجع وهو ما يحتاج لمصادر تمويل كيف ذلك
استغلال المواد الخام اساسا
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
التحقيق في اعمال يفلين بريكوجين تعتريه
اخطار كبيره
في الخامس عشر من اذار مارس 2021
وبعد نشر مقال عن مجموعه فاجنر تعرض مقر
صحيفه نوفا كازيتا لهجوم كيميائي التقطته
كاميرات المراقبه
حيث نرى رجل توصيل مزيفا يرش مدخل المبنى
بغاز سام
ان تسجل اصابات
[موسيقى]
ولكن صحفيين اخرين دفعوا حياتهم ثمنا
لتحقيقاتهم
[موسيقى]
في الثلاثين من تموز يوليو 2018
بالقرب من مدينه سيبوت قتل صحفيون كيريل
واورخان جمال
لقد حلت ثلاثه بجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
لتصوير فيلم عن مجموعه باجنر
هو والد كيرل
قبل ايام من رحيله تجدلنا حول هذه الرحله
لكنني لم اكن راغبا في تصعيد الخلاف لذا
تصالحنا قبل سفره بيوم كنا قد سمعنا عن
فاجنر ولم نكن خائفين من رجالها لاننا كنا
نقول انهم قبل كل شيء روس مثلنا
[ضحك]
كان الصحفيون الثلاثه يعملون فيتسور وهي
وسيله اعلاميه يمولها الملياردير ميخائيل
الذي سجن عشر سنوات في سيليريا واصبح
واحدا من المعارضين الرئيسيين
تاخذ القدسكي الصحفيين الثلاثه للتحقيق في
امر منجم دسم
غير ان رجال مسلحين اعترضوا طريقهم
وقتلوهم
وخلصت تحقيق في افريقيا الوسطى الى ان
الواقعه مجرد عمليه سطو على الرغم من ان
امتعتهم الشخصيه وكاميراتهم وحواسيبهم وما
معهم من نقود ظلت كما هي في السياره عندها
اطلق ميخائيل خضر كوفسكي تحقيقا واسعا
مضادا استمر عاما كاملا
حللنا الاف من ارقام الهواتف
وتمكنا نتيجه لهذا الجهد من تحديد اسماء
الاشخاص الذين ترصدوا صحفيين طوال هذه
الفتره فقد كانوا تحت المراقبه منذ اللحظه
الاولى
يمكننا الجزم بان بيجوجن ومن هم تحت
امراته هم الذين قرروا تصفيه افراد فريقنا
وكانهم يريدون ايصال رساله لنا لا نريد ان
نرى اي صحفيين استقصائيين يتحركون في
المناطق الخاضعه لسيطرتنا واولئك الذين
يحاورون الاقتراب انما يلقون بانفسهم الى
التهلوكه
[موسيقى]
ينبغي معاقبه القتله يجب ان ينالوا جزاءهم
لن استسلم ابدا
ساواصل مسائله السلطات حتى اخر رمق
وا اهدافا عشوائيه
منظومته ترتكز على محاور ثلاثه
القتال والاسراء وبث الاخبار الزائفه
وفي ضوء هذا المحور الاخير يتكفل الاخطبوط
الاعلامي باتريوت وهو مجموعه تضم
135 وسيله اعلاميه تتكفل ببث الاخبار
الملفقه وبتشويه سمعه جميع الاعداء
المفترضين لنظام الروسي من خلال مجموعه
تقارير تعتمد على مقابلات وهميه
صحفيه فرنسيه في وكاله كبابريس
وراء هذه الصحفيه تختفي اجهزه الاستخبارات
الامريكيه
طلبوا مني ان افعل شيئا مقابل المال وهو
ان اشهد امام الكاميرا واقول ان الروس
اغتصبوني
الواقع هو اننا لم نقابل او نستجوب هذه
المراه اصلا خلال رحلتنا الى
راس الحربه في امبراطوريه الاخبار المزيفه
هي وكاله ار اي فان التي يزيد متابعها عن
مئه مليون صفحه مشاهده شهريا على الشبكه
الانترنت
وهي تغرق المنصات بمحتوى معاد للغرب وتخوض
حروب كر وفر الكترونيه تؤتي ثمارها على
ارض الواقع
[موسيقى]
حصل فريق الفيلم على وثيقه داخليه من
مجموعه بادنر تشير بالاسم الى البلدان
الافريقيه المستهدفه وفقا لدرجه اهميتها
المحتمله في صداره الترتيب مستعمرات
فرنسيه سابقه
الكاميرون درجه الاهميه سبع درجات من عشر
التحليل دعم الشركات الروسيه وتوقع تغيير
في راس السلطه
مالي درجه الاهميه تسع درجات من عشر
التحليل تركز للمواد الخام كالذهب والقطن
التحليل ضعف في الاقتصاد والسيطره على
الاراضي وجود لكتيبه من القوات الفرنسيه
انا اعتقد ان بيجوجن وفاجنر والمقربين من
حاشية بوتين لن يكفوا ايديهم حتى تتصدى
لهم قوه تستطيع ان تكون ندا لهم
اذا كانت فاجنر قد حررت سوريا وجمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى
فمرحبا بها في باماكو لتحرير مالي
بينما تقلص فرنسا من وجودها في مالي يعمد
يفجين بريكوجين الى نشر وحداته هناك في
كانون الثاني يناير 2022 وصلت اولى
مجموعات مقاتلي فاجنر الى البلد
واقاموا قاعدتهم شمال مضارب ماكو في مكان
يسمى المعسكر 101
هذا سر مكشوف نحن نعلم بوجود حوالي 300
او 400 من مسلح فاغنر منذ بدايه كانون
الثاني يناير وقد اعلنوا انهم يهدفون الى
تعداد قدره الف وهنا يطفو على سطح مره
اخرى قانون البقاء للاقوى في العلاقات
الدوليه فمن يخاطر ياخذ اهتمام المبادره
واعتقد ان خصومنا يقدمون الاداء على
الاخلاق
اني
لم تعد الدول الغربيه تدرك ان الدفاع عن
مصالح معينه يتطلب الاستعداد للموت
ان اليوم الذي نتطلع اليه جميعا حيث سياده
السلام
وحل المشاكل في محادثات وديه هو يوم لم
يبزغ فجره بعد
سيدفع ضرب الثمن دروس كما ان الدرس سيكون
مريرا وقاسيا
[موسيقى]
مين
المتهورين الذين يستسهلون اعدام الافارقه
الفقراء فهؤلاء ليسوا خصومنا ما اعنيه
بقوله هو ان هدفنا هو العالم الغربي
بايديولوجيته وقيمه لقد نشانا نشاه مختلفه
وننظر الى العالم نظره مختلفه
[موسيقى]